welcome
to apple's walled garden where the
company's hardware
and software and services have formed
these very high walls around you
so you can never leave
if you own an iphone and at least one
other apple gadget
you live here with me in this
metaphorical walled garden
which for journalistic purposes brought
us to this real-world garden
in tech a walled garden is a closed
ecosystem of products
and with antitrust scrutiny and the epic
first apple lawsuit
lately you hear a lot about apple's
walled garden
walled garden walled garden to lock in
users to its walled garden
so how did apple's walls get so high and
is it even a bad thing that it's
difficult to climb out and explore
products from other companies like
google samsung and microsoft when do
these walls get so high
come take a garden tour with me i'm
going to help you understand
this real walled garden here in yonkers
new york has many different areas
just like apples let's start here at the
entrance
with your apple hardware without it you
can't enter the garden
no these sections are not to scale
definitely not according to apple
revenue
your journey into the garden likely
started with an iphone
then you bought an apple watch or
airpods because they work so well with
the iphone
and maybe you also have an ipad or
macbook
and now you're here forever many
companies like samsung and google have
families of products too
but what makes apple stronger is its
full control of the next part of the
garden
this big section here is apple's
software that means
ios and mac os and watch os and ipad os
all of these have apple only features
that tie them together to work better
together
they don't work with android phones or
windows computers
the list is long but let's look at a few
there's icloud
this syncs all your photos documents
notes etc
across devices there's airdrop this
makes it easy to share a file from one
apple device to another
there's airplay this makes it easier to
play music or video
say apple tv plus's own ted lasso from
an apple device on another apple device
there's the underlying continuity this
lets you hand off a web page email
or another activity quickly from your
iphone on another apple device
and then there's the ultimate one
imessage
apple's messaging system lets you send
and receive messages
and stickers and games and money but
only on apple devices
and to people with apple devices it's
the ultimate blue bubble wall
final big area of the garden apple
services
in this first services area you have
everything from apple tv plus
what's a computer to apple music to
apple fitness plus
push-ups here they are everyone with
most of these you have to pay more in
the form of monthly subscriptions
good thing i'm at this garden by myself
and apple often uses its power over the
platform
to persuade you for instance this
perpetual pop-up in my settings menu
some of these services are available for
other gardens like android or windows
but the experience is always better on
an apple device and then there's one
very big
service here the app store think of it
as a large pool
inside a walled garden the ios app store
is the only app store allowed on iphones
and ipads
there are lots of apps in the pool but
apple's the fish
eating 15 to 30 of paid app revenue
and even digital in-app purchases oh
that one's even 30
of that app revenue right there this has
been at the heart of complaints from
other tech companies
like in the epic games lawsuit zoom out
to see the whole map and it's quite the
business lesson
every part keeps you with apple and
spending more money with apple
the first third is what gets you in the
second where it gets you to start using
and buying even more from section one
the third you buy more stuff except it's
digital stuff on your devices
study that if you want to build the next
two trillion dollar company so you can
see
as the garden grows the walls grow
higher and higher
so it's even harder to get out of here
but is it really all that bad
it's called a walled garden because the
stuff inside is very pretty
and works great so you may not even want
to peek over the wall to see what
samsung or microsoft or google has on
the other side
and apple argues that many of its walls
protect user privacy
and security specifically it says its
walled app store
keeps out malware and other bad actors
the not so great stuff starts to show
when you try to bring a competitor into
the garden
say switching to a windows laptop or an
android phone
the serenity of the garden can be
disrupted
since there's no imessage for android
for instance you could suddenly miss out
on contacts or even groups
in fact an internal email surfaced in
the epic vs apple trial
an apple executive said imessage on
android would simply serve to remove an
obstacle to iphone families giving their
kids
android phones hey if apple's garden is
so good
why does it need these walls to keep us
in there's also the argument that it
stifles innovation
if apple keeps making its own versions
of products do we miss out on
new ideas and innovations and when it
comes to the app store swimming pool
developers argue apple is unfairly
abusing its power to charge developers
more
while the legal battles about this
garden will play out in anti-trust suits
and more over the next
few years there are a few ways apple
users can poke
little holes in apple's garden walls if
there's a good alternative to an apple
service like spotify for apple music
give it a real chance you shouldn't just
choose to use services because they're
right there on our devices
then if you pay for a subscription
through the app store find out what the
app charges on its own website for the
same service
you get a surprise discount also apple
has over the years allowed you to change
your default web browser or email app
so no you might not even want to climb
out or dig out
but breaking a few holes in the walls
might let a little
more sunshine in hey tim just imessage
on android and windows
think about it just think about it